est-ce que ça fait au revoir comme ça
doit avoir une partie de sa vie ben ça
fait plaisir
et c est aussi un peu un peu prenant
c'est un peu émouvant mais vous savez le
une vie vous l'avez dit c'est une vie
une carrière c'est une vie et cet
hommage à ma carrière ça n'est pas non
plus la fin de quelque chose on peut
aussi avoir un amas j'ai regardé aussi
devant soi et pas seulement derrière
j'ai déjà eu un hommage en 64 et ça m'a
permis de continuer quand même donc ça
n'est pas la fin de quelque chose mais
c'est assez ça me toujours très curieux
de voir cela mais je dois dire que cette
rétrospective là aussi brève ne soit
elle est assez remarquable et ça m'a
fait très très très chaud au coeur alors
alain delon je vais vous poser quelques
questions comme ça une sorte
d'inventaire à la prévert josé pas mis
dans l'ordre vous êtes arrivé l'envers
l'abécédaire non non pas du tout
rassurez vous vous êtes arrivé dans le
cinéma vous êtes devenu très rapidement
une star au bout de deux ou trois films
qu'est ce qui fait la différence entre
un acteur qui reste un comédien est
quelqu'un qui devient une star c'est
quoi c'est alors pour expliquer
longtemps là j'ai déjà expliqué la
différence essentielle entre un comédien
et un acteur un comédien
d'ailleurs une vocation c'est un métier
et un acteur c'est presque une
improvisation c'est une personnalité
forte en général mise au service de
quelque chose en l'occurrence du cinéma
moi je fais partie des acteurs au même
titre que gabin lancaster lino ventura
qui sont des gens qui ne sont pas venues
d'une formation de comédien ni d'acteur
ça c'est la différence essentielle c'est
vrai qu'on voit mal alain delon ou jean
gabin au cours florent par exemple ben
on ne les a jamais vus ce n'est pas
péjoratif du tout pour les comédiens
alors on a souvent dit de vous que vous
étiez une star et on le dit toujours et
en même temps vous êtes quelqu'un de
marginal par rapport au milieu du cinéma
vous n'avez jamais beaucoup fréquenté
d'abord parce que ma vie dans le cinéma
est un accident ce n'est pas quelque
chose que j'ai souhaité faire je ne vais
pas voulu je ne vais pas chercher je ne
vais pas demander c'est arrivé comme ça
par as à la incidemment par hasard et
lorsque vous ne cherchez pas les choses
en général les choses durent moi toute
ma vie je me suis dit ça va pas durer il
faut que je pense à l'avenir et que je
fasse que je prépare quelque chose
d'autre et ça ne s'est jamais arrêté
donc c'est comme ça veut dire je les
accepte et et puis je j'en suis très
heureux parce que il faut vous dire que
le métier que j'ai fait le sûrement le
plus beau métier du monde du nom d'un an
schisme en exceptionnel j'ai fait 87
films et je peux vous dire que
pratiquement 87 films ses 87 vie et ça
ça ça permet d'avoir un tonus
exceptionnelle alors vous dites aussi
certains metteurs en scène avec qui
j'aurais aimé tourner on tue peur de moi
je le dis parce que parce que certains
me l'ont dit par exemple comme truffaut
pourquoi je ne sais pas je ne suis pas
là pour le demander à truffaut mais
parce qu'il m'a dit j'aimerais beaucoup
faire un film avec vous mais quelque
part vous me faites peur je lui dis
alors ça c'est comme une bêtise on ne
peut pas faire plus plus énormes et puis
je ne sais pas parce que il ya beaucoup
de metteurs en scène aussi qu'ils ont
peur quelque part qu'une un acteur
disons leur prenne guinée sous forme de
préséance leur prennent la vedette ou
leur prenne ça n'a jamais été mon
ambition n'est mon désir moi je fus j'ai
fait toute ma vie j'ai travaillé avec
des gens très important et je ne vois
jamais jamais rien pris en général je
m'évertue de leur apporter quelque chose
alors vous êtes très populaire au japon
pourquoi oui je l'étais je le suis
maintenant je les ai été pendant
effectivement c'est une longue histoire
d'amour de 30 ans avec le pourquoi parce
que les japonais pour faire bref c'était
ty ensuite identifié à moi vous savez
qu'au japon il ya quand même un tout
petit complexe de couleur de peau de
race il envie leblanc vous admire le
blanc et il avait une passion pour il
était très très très fortement les
admirais tout ce qui était français et
le japonais c'est est identifié à moins
s'il avait voulu s'il avait eu la chance
dit il d'être blanc il aurait voulu
ressembler alain delon là ça va mais une
question qu'on vous pose toujours de
manière un petit peu alambiqué on this a
dû être terrible d'être beau comme alain
delon salut est fantastique c'est
fantastique d'être beau écouter avoir
toutes les femmes que vous vouliez etc
etc
moi je trouve dans un virage et la vie
ne se limite pas à ça mais ont reçu des
facettes de la vie c'est aussi important
mais je veux dire ça je n'en suis pas
responsable en général je dis toujours
c'est vraiment aider les gens les
profiter et je le dis et je le reconnais
c'est ce qui me permettent souvent de
dire qu'il n'ya pas d'égalité des
chances parce qu'il ya des êtres au
départ hommes ou femmes qui naissent
différents et différemment des autres et
déjà c'est une énorme chance et un
énorme potentiel davantage au début il
faut un savoir acquis mais voilà dans le
cinéma ce n'est pas toujours facile
parce qu'au début il ne suffit pas
d'être beau après il faut perdurer et ça
ça n'a plus rien à voir
des pas du tout att c'était quand vous
rentrez quelque part ça fantastique que
tout le monde vous regarde les femmes
notamment
c'était vous voulez dire et j'ai dit ce
n est pas pour employer le passé oui
mais enfin bon c'est passé à ses façades
le plus important bien vous avez les ans
ça n'avait pas de sens
voilà la même chose l on verra déplaise
alors vous avez un projet de théâtre
pourquoi vous vous lancez dans le
théâtre vous avez 300 parents ou les
bars ou même louis partait dans le
théâtre c'est terrible tiers parce que
vous avez très mauvais souvenirs en
théâtre en fait pas du tout qui vous a
dit d'emblée le terrain on me ça fait
trembler tous les acteurs dignes de ce
nom parce qu'ils sont conscient et
lucide elle veut dire qui et qui
les gens qui n'ont pas le trac vous
savez n'ont pas beaucoup de talent en
général alors j'ai eu deux expériences
théâtrales absolument fabuleuse une avec
visconti avec raymond rouleau et maribel
bien sûr et des acteurs exceptionnels et
on m'a souvent posé la question puisque
maintenant j'ai pu faire des plaintes
depuis 28 ans pourquoi ne revenez vous
pas ota djezzy parce que je n'ai rien
trouvé qui m'excite suffisamment pour
les ramener au projet parce que ça n'est
pas non plus ma formation je suis un
acteur comédien de théâtre et j'ai j'ai
finalement trouvé une pièce fabuleuse
qui m'excite énormément qui est une
pièce tout à fait nouvelle moderne
d'haneda l'auteur très talentueux qui
s'appelle eric emmanuel schmitt et j'ai
donc décidé de refaire du théâtre et
dans les meilleurs conditions puisque je
vais jouer avec francis huster qui lui
est un grand comédien de théâtre à mes
côtés au trac mariniers merci alain
delon je dois dire qu'entre temps vous
allez voir aussi une très grande star
puisque vous avez tourné avec lauren
bacall
oui ca s'élève encore un des derniers
grands mythes vivants puisque bacall
sebo guilbault guy bogaert évidemment
c'est toute l'histoire du grand cinéma
du vrai cinéma celui que j'aime merci
alain de laurent primaire
[Musique]